welcome into another edition of Market
takes you know I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me I appreciate that I am Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal this is Market takes we are
doing a look ahead uh we're gonna talk
through you know there's a lot going on
in the economy but there are three big
things that you need to be watching out
for this week we are going to go through
break down all of them what they are why
they matter and what you should be
looking out there looking out for this
week the first is the state of housing
we have four big reports out this week
I'm gonna explain what they are and why
each of them matters next we have
earnings of course last week you know we
got earnings season kicked off you heard
from the big Banks but this week is
going to be an even more important uh
week of earnings for the banking sector
and for the economy I'm going to tell
you why that is and what to look out for
third we have there's been a lot of talk
about the weakening U.S dollar a lot of
worries about the dollars uh Global
prospects and things like that we are
going to talk about the state of the
dollar and a report that comes out this
week that could tell us a little bit
more give some context on the state of
the dollar so we're going to talk about
all of that right now so let's get into
it let's start talking about housing and
why things are getting better in the
housing sector and why maybe that's not
such a good thing so first chart I want
to put up here on your screen is the
nahb housing market index now we
actually just got the latest update for
that report out right now at the start
of Market takes and that report came in
higher than last month now you see there
on your screen the last four months you
see the report just going up up higher
well it went even higher April this
month the last month you see there is 44
for March in April it went up to 45 so
that index just showing the overall pace
of price increases of confidence of
consumers of Builders and things like
that and that has been picking up now
you normally think okay that's a good
thing the economy is growing but that
might not be such a good thing because
we're seeing all of the housing market
indicators move in exactly this same
direction so that chart there
illustrating overall home builder
confidence and the pace of increases in
prices we are seeing that exact same
kind of trend where things have been
moving lower lower the FED raised
interest rates they're trying to slow
down the economy they want consumers to
reconsider their purchasing decisions
not take on more credit and that's they
want they want to see things come down
and get lower and get worse and so
there's less confidence less borrowing
less spending but that's not what we've
seen the past three months going all the
way back and now past four or five
months all the way through December of
last year we have seen a pickup and an
increase and that continued in April now
we're also seeing that in housing starts
we get the latest housing starts data on
Tuesday that last month accelerated 9.8
almost 10 percent month over month that
was the fastest Pace in September home
construction also home construction have
been trending lower and those housing
starts number tells us about what
Builders are doing they're actually
starting housing projects that picked up
in a big weight almost 10 percent last
month we will see if that continues
tomorrow a big piece of that was
multi-family which we know is people
putting money investing in units for
renting out rather than for Lending
rather than for living uh we also get
the mortgage the mba's weekly mortgage
application survey last week the 30-year
fixed rate fell to 6.3 percent the
lowest level in two months and we saw
applications for mortgages increased by
eight percent Mike Fred and Tony he is
the svb and the chief Economist of the
SVP excuse me senior vice president at
the Mortgage Bankers Association and
their Chief Economist he said that
prospective home buyers this year have
been quite sensitive to any drop in
mortgage rates mortgage rates drop into
6.3 percent now that's a little lower
but remember a year or two ago you saw
mortgage rates down about that three
handle and we're getting up to the
forehandle now mortgage rates still high
still at 6.3 percent but you're seeing
housing starts pick up you're seeing
mortgage applications pick up and
everything the fed is doing to try to
slow the economy is kind of being undone
slowly but surely remember mortgages
mortgage rates housing all those things
were the first thing to slow down when
the FED first started raising interest
rates now they're starting to pick back
up as the FED is expected to slow down
its interest rate hiking cycle
um the markets are showing one more
expected increase in May next month and
then cut starting in July well consumers
are responding taking on more mortgages
more debts and we're seeing how housing
starts picked back up we've seen the
housing market index pick back up we
also will get the existing home sales
report out on Thursday last month we saw
existing home sales Rise by almost 15
percent we are going to be right here
Thursday breaking down the existing home
sales report uh telling you why that
happens that could be a big Market mover
because existing homes are most of the
economy or most of the market when it
comes to mortgages so be with us right
here on Market takes Thursday at noon
we'll break all that down now let's talk
about earnings really quickly last week
we had Bank earnings for the big Banks
JP Morgan Citigroup Wells Fargo all big
booming blowout earnings JP Morgan said
profit was up 52 percent first quarter
38.3 billion dollars in Revenue Wells
Fargo five billion dollars Citigroup 4.6
billion dollars PNC Bank another big one
1.7 billion dollars these are huge big
booming numbers JP Morgan shares extra
Rose seven and a half percent that was
the number one stock in the S P 500 on
Friday and then you had Citigroup up 5
4.8 percent the second best the second
biggest increase in the overall S P 500
but let's throw something up here on
your screen I want to put that number or
those numbers in context so you can see
just how much folks in the investing
Community are really responding to that
that huge drop happened after svb and
you see that there at the edge of your
screen that's the Friday response so
investors okay well banks are doing a
little bit better and remember this
index you're seeing is mostly the big
Banks it's mostly Citigroup it's mostly
JP Morgan Bank of America even those big
blowout earnings weren't enough to
really get investors excited about the
banks and you see a little pickup but
not that much so that just illustrates
that investors are not sold that banks
are back there's still a lot of worry
about the banking sector and we will
find out this week we get reports from
Ally Fifth Third M T Bank Western
Alliance Zion KeyBank some of these
Regional banks that are the ones most in
trouble we saw JPMorgan CFO Jeremy
Barnum said there's about 50 billion
dollars of deposit inflows in the first
quarter that's largely coming from those
Regional Banks we are going to find out
how those Regional Banks did this week
and expect the numbers to not be so
great and that could cause another
sell-off in the market look out for that
we also get earnings from Johnson and
Johnson Netflix Tesla United Airlines
and a big one I think is going to be
Schwab those earnings are going to be
key watch out for that last thing we
want to talk about here on Market takes
is the weak dollar we there has been all
kinds of talk about this folks have been
worried news headlines popping up here
and there also you've seen Secretary of
the Treasury Janet Yellen gave an
interview where she was asked directly
about the state of the dollar so want to
throw something on your screen here
really quickly to just show you the
movement overall you see there the
dollar is clearly down this year but
that movement has been up and down and
you see at the edge of your screen there
on the right picking back up investors
are very strongly positioned right now
speculative investors for a big pickup
and an increase in the in the dollar
this year their their position net long
on the dollar against just about every
other major currency out there so that
chart illustrating the overall
positioning right now that we've seen
we've seen the dollar decline a little
bit it's weaker but historically not
that big a move I want to read you a
real quick quote from secretary yellin
she said quote there is a risk when we
use Financial sanctions that are linked
to the role of the dollar that over time
it could undermine the hegemony of the
dollar what that means is the value of
the dollar the ability and the
omnipresence of the dollar and you in
Global Financial systems there's a risk
there we've seen talk from China from
Russia Russia there's been a long-term
push against the dollar because they
don't want the United States to be able
to sanction them to cause economic pain
if they don't use the dollar well the
U.S can't cut them out of the banking
system Etc et cetera but as you saw from
that chart the dollar has declined in
value a little bit but investors not
buying that story thing and okay the
Dollar's power and strength is going to
come back and that over the course of
time over the course even of this year
we will be back we are at historically
strong levels for the dollar and folks
are thinking okay that dollar strength
is gonna come back because maybe
interest rates are picking up this
really is a story more about the Federal
Reserve and central banks and the
expectation for the European Central
Bank to raise rates more than the fed
this isn't about people not using a
dollar or the dollar going away just
wanted to make that clear and this week
we will hear from the fed the fed's
beige book is out on Wednesday that's
going to tell us how the FED is seeing
the overall economy they talk to a lot
of businesses and they say hey what's
going on in your District in your area
we will get that report on Wednesday
listen that's going to do it for us here
on Market takes like I said I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you were here with me and I
appreciate that Thursday we'll be
breaking down the existing home sales
report at noon be here or be a
as a square don't do it listen that's
going to do it from Market takes I'm
Dion rabone report at the Wall Street
Journal we will see you next time
foreign